Aïe ! Ouh ça va !
C'est juste une égratignure,heureusement
que je suis vacciné contre le tétanos.
Avec toute cette rouille, c'est vite arrivé hein.
Mais bon je vais quand même vérifier
et puis ce sera l'occasion dereparler
des bactéries, des virus, des vaccins.
Comment ils fonctionnent parcequ'en ce moment
on entend des verteset des pas mûres.
Allez une petite piqûre derappel,
ça fera pas de mal.
Alors ... où je l'ai mit ?
Ah ! Le voilà, mon carnet de santé.
Ilfaut toujours savoir où on l'a rangé.
Faudra quand même que je pense
à faire monrappel.
Un vaccin, c'est une substancequi permet
à notre système immunitaire,
autrement dit nos défenses naturelles
de s'entraîner à lutter contre certains
microbes des bactéries ou des virus
et de les détruire quand ils pénètrent dans notre organisme.
Je vais vous montrer.
Considérons que l’atelier représente l'organisme.
Les microbes, que ce soient les virus ou les bactéries,
sont protégés par uneenveloppe.
La surface des virus, vous le voyez,
est parfois recouvertes de proéminence.
On parle de spicules.
Tiens, celui-ci vous le reconnaissez,
on ne parle que de lui depuis des mois.
Le SARS Cov 2, un coronavirus.
On l’appelle ainsi parce que tous ces spicules
forment une couronne autour de lui.
Leurs enveloppes, que ce soit pour
le virus ou les bactéries,
sont constitués de protéines notamment,
des molécules dont certaines sont propres à chaquemicrobes
et qu'on appelle des antigènes.
Je les aient représentés en orange sur ce virus,
en rouge sur celui-ci et en bleu sur la bactérie.
Des antigènes propres à chaque microbes.
Très bien, je note !
An-ti-gène
Ça pique un peu hein, faudra bien penser à
prendre de cachets hein, monsieur Jamy.
Alors le microbe pénétrer dans l'organisme
par différentesportes.
Les voies respiratoires,
la bouche, lesmuqueuses.
Tiens ! Ça tombe bien.
Tu ressemblesun virus toi, qui pénètre dans l'organisme.
Prenons l’exemple d’un virus.
Une fois dans l’organisme, il pénètre dans les cellules.
Pas n'importe lesquels. Chaque virus a sa cible.
Certains visent les cellules du système
respiratoire par exemple.
Comment rentre-il?
Pour faire simple disons que chaque virus possède une clé spécifique
et que les cellules visées possèdent la serrure.
Une fois dans la cellule le virus, prend le contrôle de cette cellule,
il s’y multiplie et parfois la détruit.
Alors évidemment on ne se laisse pas faire,
grâce à notre système immunitaire, on se défend.
On représente aussi souvent notre système immunitaire sous les traits
d’une forteresse et d’une armée de petits soldats.
Dès que notre système immunitaire détecte un intrus,
un virus par exemple, c’est branle-bas de combat!
En fait il reconnaît les fameuses antigènes
donton a parlé tout à l'heure.
Dès lors, toute unecascade de réactions s'enclenche,
qui impliqueles fidèles soldats du système immunitaire :
les globules blancs.
Certains d’entre eux disposent d’une arme redoutable: les anticorps.
Ils se lient aux antigènes et permettent aux autres
globules blancs de repérer et d'éliminer levirus.
Éventuellement les cellules infectées.
Le bonus, c’est qu’ une fois le microbe éliminé,
une petite population de cellules immunitaires,
qui a été «activée» par l’intrus,
est stockée dans les ganglions lymphatiques,
sous les aisselles parexemple ou
dans la moelle osseuse.
Elles gardent en mémoire, vous le voyez,
l’antigène du microbe qui a été vaincu.
Résultat: si celui-ci a l’audace de nous attaquer à nouveau,
le système immunitaire le reconnaît immédiatement
et se met en route beaucoup plus rapidement
et plus efficacement que la première fois.
Il ne laisse alors aucune chance à l’envahisseur!
Cette mémoire immunologique peut durer des années, voire toute la vie!
C’est pour cela que la plupart des personnes qui attrapent la varicelle
durant leur enfance en sont protégées pour le restant de leurs jours.
Et le vaccin dans tout ça?
Il faut que vous fasse une petite piqure de rappel ?
J'y viens !
Le problème c’est que notre système immunitaire
a parfois du mal à faire face ou à se mettre en action.
Le virus ou la bactérie peuvent faire de gros dégâts
avant d’être stoppé, voire ne pas être stoppé du tout.
C’est le cas avec le tétanos, la tuberculose
ou le SARS-CoV-2 chez certaines personnes.
Le principe du vaccin consiste à simuler la première attaque d’un microbe pour que le système immunitaire s’entraine à le combattre.
Ainsi, le jour où nous sommes exposés,
involontairement cette fois, à ce virus ou à cette bactérie,
notre système immunitaire réagit au quart de tour!
L’astuce, est bien sûr que le vaccin doit servir à créer une mémoire immunologique mais sans rendre malade!
On ne peut donc pas vacciner quelqu’un en
lui injectant simplement le microbe en pleine forme.
Il a fallu biaisé, on lui injecte un leurre.
Je vais vous montrer.
D’abord il y a ce qu‘on appelle
les vaccins atténués
comme ceux mis au point pour lutter contre les oreillons,
la rougeole, la fièvre jaune.
Ceux-ci contiennent un microbe entier, vivant,
mais qui a été sélectionné, vous le voyez,
parce qu’il n’est pas assez virulent
pour rendre malade.
Ensuite il y a les microbes inactivés,
c’est le cas du vaccin contre de la grippe.
Là, le virus est entier mais les chercheurs l’ont tué, en l’exposant
par exemple à des rayons UV ou à la chaleur.
Certains vaccins ne contiennent que des morceaux du microbe,
certaines protéines par exemple.
C’est le cas par exemple du vaccin
contre le papillomavirus.
L’avantage de ces vaccins c’est qu’ils sont sans risque, même pour
les personnes ayant un système immunitaire déficient.
L’inconvénient, c’est que la réponse immunitaire est souvent moins forte et
que la mémoire immunologique dure donc moins longtemps.
C’est pour cette raison que pour certains vaccins,
il faut de temps en temps faire un rappel,
histoire de rappeler le microbe aux bons souvenirs
de nos globules blancs et se refaire une santé.
L' «ARNm» qu'ils ont dit,
j’en vois pas moi de route nationale «m» ?
Mais non ARNm… acide ribonucléique  «m» pour messager.
Cette fois il ne s’agit plus d’injecter le virus
ou une partie du virus mais la recette
pour que nos propres cellules puissent
fabriquer un morceau du virus.
Allez ! Suivez moi parce que là on peut vraiment
en faire un fromage.
Le virus possède sous son enveloppe, son propre ADN.
On parle parfois degénomes une succession de gênes.
Il s'agit enfait d'un programme sur lequel figurent
toutes lesinstructions qui sont nécessaires
à la fabricationdes différents éléments du virus
et de toutes cescaractéristiques.
Le problème du virus c'est qu'ils ne possèdent
pas d'outils pour lire et exécuter ceprogramme.
Voilà pourquoi il infecte les cellules humaines,
qui elles possèdent leur propre ADN
et toute une machinerie pour exécuter ce programme.
En infectant les cellules humaines, le virus
vadétourner cette machinerie pour se multiplier.
Revenons à l'ARN messager.
Eh bien c'est la copied'un petit morceau de l'ADN du virus.
Un petit morceau qui correspond à un gène,
le gène qui codepour la fabrication de l'antigène
ce fameux antigène qui se trouve à la surface du virus.
Celuidont on a parlé au début de cette vidéo
et qui permet au système immunitaire
de reconnaître levirus.
Le vaccin ARN messager consiste donc
à injecter les instructions
pour que nos cellulesse met
à produire l'antigène caractéristiques duvirus.
Une fois dans notre organisme,
le système immunitaire va lutter contre lui
et s'entraînerà reconnaître et à combattre le virus.
C’est cette méthode qui est utilisée
par plusieurs laboratoires pour lutter contre le SARS-CoV-2.
Elle ne date pas d’hier. Les chercheurs travaillent dessus
depuis 30 ans et heureusement.
Il a seulement fallu trouver le moyen de
transporter l’ARN jusqu’au cellules.
Là encore, comme il n’est pas présent en entier,
il ne risque pas de se reproduire et de nous rendre malade!
Quant à l'ARN du vaccin, il estrapidement
détruit par notre système immunitaire.
En quelques jours, il n’en reste plus de trace
dans notre corps.
En revanche, la mémoire de notre système immunitaire est prête
et attend désormais de pied ferme le véritable virus.
Ba je ne sais pas pour vous mais là, je me sens mieux.
Et je me sentiraiencore beaucoup mieux
quand je pourrais lire dans mon carnet de santé
que j'ai été vacciné contre la
covid-19.